hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to align the Kido an
intermittent fasting pattern around your
lifestyle now I've gotten some feedback
from certain people who do this and they
have a hard time transitioning Akito
adapting because at work they're tired
and when they need the most mental
energy they're a little sluggish and
they had a problem with that so here's
one thing you could do very easily to
solve that problem and have a little
more energy especially in the beginning
of doing this in the early part of the
day okay here's what you do basically
keeping the breakfast
keeping the lunch and omit the dinner
okay so what you could do to make the
transition to start out is go ahead and
start with a breakfast okay and then
just don't eat until you're hungry so
that could maybe be like I don't know
three o'clock something like that now if
you were to eat at 8 o'clock in the
morning and then at 12 o'clock noon that
would give you 20 hours of fasting so if
we compare doing it this way versus
consuming maybe a lunch and a dinner
with a four-hour window let's take a
look at just a difference there number
one your stomach is mostly acid in the
morning which means it's ready to digest
the protein so let's say you did a lot
of your protein and your fats in the
morning versus in the evening okay that
may be better for your digestion the
other benefit is that this would prevent
you going to sleep with your stomach
feeling a bit bloated
because some people when they have
dinner they feel really full and so by
the time they're going to bed they feel
kind of stuffed and your digestion if
it's not right will definitely keep you
from sleeping so doing it this pattern
will allow your stomach and your
digestion to be low stress so you go
into a nice sleep cycle without your
body having to work too hard on the
digestion so this is just another option
to see if this may align with your work
schedule a little bit better especially
if you need maybe more mental energy in
the first part of the day right here
if you have digestive stress you might
want to try this pattern right here
alright thanks for watching hey I
appreciate your attention and if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated on future events live events and
webinars that we're going to do very
soon